back oh my god it's so hard to get naked
in the wilderness
[Music]
[Music]
nature stuff cliff bar has a new product
the cliff nut Butterfield energy bar
because of that we're in the middle of
nowhere gonna have an outdoor adventure
I used to be a Boy Scout actually an
Eagle Scout my doctor has recommended
hiking as a nice low impact activity so
I'm coming today with the real intrepid
spirit and an adventurers heart you
might think that the challenge is
surviving nature but nay challenges
surviving your friends last time we were
in the wilderness
we were told we would have died so we're
back baby I think a lot of what we do is
relatively crazy we really just love
being outdoors and so that has brought
us to all these different challenges you
guys are married so it's being married
important when you're out in the
wilderness
absolutely so what is our day of
adventure looking like you're gonna
start here you're gonna go through a
meadow to the burnt forest to a river
which you're gonna have to cross and
then you're gonna go from the river and
you're gonna meet us at a rock climbing
wall how many miles are we talking about
here probably around like 10 to 12 you
don't get to luck why are you doing this
to us
Adventure starts at the end of your
comfort zone we really want you guys to
be able to make your way through with
the tools that you have but also making
sure that you guys work together or is
it this route we've designated packs for
each of you enjoy your high nutrition
super-important just making sure you
keep your energy sustain the whole time
you already eat it come on I gotta be
prepared no Keith we're not busy yet I
got a first-aid kit in case anyone gets
the boo-boo oh it's a compass
okay this is great oh that's so it's
probably supposed to go in mine actually
well do you know how to read a
topographical map do you know how to
read topographical map yeah and we
should just leave them because we have
all the water to
you're kind of getting on my stuff with
Ned leading with Eugene leading we know
what that video is so today I'm taking
control well number one we got ticket
number one Hebraic that's terrible
leadership style try and find a rock to
pee on shouldn't we pee on trees
yeah no because there's quite a bit of
salt content in your feet as long as I
get to tell everyone where we should go
and what route to take I'm gonna be fine
no one can annoy me North is that way
that way didn't it all just want to
confirm that you did great I grew up in
Tennessee which has a lot of woods but I
wasn't really a woods boy I was more of
a couch kid I thought I would hate this
but you know it's actually quite pretty
today all I want to do is use something
sharp and enjoy peaceful day in the wild
okay put the knife away
put the knife away number one you sliced
your thumb on an avocado Jenna's a
butter knife yes friendship is really
important when you're out in wilderness
it's all about encouragement Wow like a
drawing kid I'm like the artist of the
groups and Ed you're basically useless
artists vlog three hours in you don't
ask for art art asks for you this is
your dress in the middle of nowhere why
not just keep wandering
bring out the map we're going that way
because we are out in this beautiful
environment I try to leave the places
that I visit cleaner than when I got
there we named him cliff
Clifton clipton Barrington let's see
what you got Annette is lifting the
caterpillar it's really bad
hey guys look right there in the field
hey Zack that's what teamwork happens
[Music]
either sign to her computer and I decide
hurt my feet hurt these trees look like
they survived the fire don't want to be
really mindful of where you're putting
your feet not stepping on fresh
vegetation don't walk in a single-file
line
so not single-file we're like a boy band
yeah guys we just talked about for a
second it got very beautiful very
quickly right the boys are having a
photo shoot now yes it's awful
Eugene I made you a present what is it
[Music]
do you like this
alright guys full see man I hear a river
Unser's our preview controls all my ways
across the towering River where's the
bridge there's nowhere to cross it
there's supposed to be a bridge you
broke bridges and roads cities the
prison road map those are rivers are you
talking about their mirrors how would I
know that these are not they're not why
we're gonna be roses amount Jack can you
just let me help you no because if I
give it to you you're gonna take it away
and not let me help
I don't want it Chris and Kimmi
entrusted me with this map if you find
two trees you can always send one person
across not in your shoes and your
clothes and once the first person goes
across with the rope I have that and
then have everything valuable in the
backpack and kind of just send it down
[Music]
[Music]
that's the hard work hitting our work
[Music]
[Music]
Eugene I want to be the mom here but I
know you haven't eaten yeah did you eat
did you read your team I think it's
about time you have one so we're
supposed to go directly up that way but
that's the little thief just remember
you're hiking up this hill to go climb
up another the preliminary hill take
your time make sure that you can carry
on a conversation without breathing
really hard oh I don't know dad have
given the season high ladies and
gentlemen I was never a boy scout do it
great oh that's cute we make sure North
is pointing north I kind of feel like I
totally like chill within your capable
hands right now the art Minh and the
bossman losing steam
[Music]
yeah yeah I'm not thrilled that's huge
that's enormous you can do it buddy you
guys made it you believe it can I just
say from down here you two look
beautiful and majestic I actually do a
picture of you guys I see it so we're
gonna climb this rock wall yes you are
what is this rock face called this whole
area is matrimony wall what we're gonna
want to look for the biggest hold for
your hands and feet your feet could do a
lot of work and they could help
how are you up to climb a lockbox you
want to go first Oh Nate I I know we've
been through a lot today but yeah will
you have me there's only one direction
to go let's do this climbing climbing
[Applause]
I'm gonna go nice and slow you know one
grip at a time right yeah yeah yeah you
look good
okay feels like we got through the
harder part I think Eve is legitimately
afraid of who's playing this kind of
stuff yeah yeah hey well thanks very
much this has been great
I'll see you huddle you can do it okay
yeah
climbing climbing I'm waiting
climb on Oh God great time you guys you
got it one step at a time
hey earnest yes this is terrifying yeah
you got it you're doing amazing you get
afraid you just have to kind of bring
yourself back to where you are where do
I cram at this point think about where
you are don't get too overwhelmed you
guys
don't look down you're good during this
first fiance this batch money rack
plucky
I got you baby
no it was constant fear and worry no way
around
what an adventure that was amazing
usually when you throw the try guys out
in the wilderness together we end up
trying to kill each other but today I
think we actually worked the best we've
ever worked together I'm usually so
focused on the destination but I feel
like I kind of got to enjoy the journey
a little bit today look at where we are
look at what we did it reminds me of how
beautiful and how amazing this planet is
and how lucky we are to share it you
know about me I don't really exercise so
this is a great challenge for me to do
all of the exercising I've done this
year all at once this is me discovering
my artistic side if you look closely I'm
holding a drawing of me it's covering my
artistic side
I wanted to you know touch a deer or
bear Z you've been fawning over deer all
day